[Musica]
[Applauso]
la vostra memoria è ancora buona il
temperino alla moneta non è una favola
di fedro di cui non ricordate il
contenuto il titolo del mio tocco un po
balzano se volete è frutto della mia
immaginazione ed è volutamente
provocatorio
stasera voglio stupirvi
non parlerò di innovazione finanziaria
di block cei di cripto valute e non
svelerò ai voi il segreto per
l'investimento giusto da fare il tema di
cui voglio parlare è invece incertezza
vi confesso che la scelta del tema
risale a circa un mese fa ricevo
un'email dal team di ted in cui mi
chiedono a che punto fosse sono in alto
mare tempo dieci secondi e ricevo una
telefonata
preoccupatissima andrea tutto bene cosa
succede
ho un dubbio
rispondo io non so se parlare di
innovazione finanziaria come tutti si
aspettano o se invece parlare di
incertezza certamente l'innovazione
finanziaria degli ultimi tempi e temi
interessantissimo ma c'è qualcosa che ho
forse più a cuore ed è sfatare un mito
che dilaga il mito che l'incertezza sia
sempre comunque portatrice di cattive
notizie
così ho deciso come spesso mi capita di
pormi nel mezzo il tema principale sarà
incertezza ma appoggerò alcune mie
riflessioni sulle innovazioni
finanziarie
scusate forse ho bisogno di una
bottiglietta prima di cominciare
accettate temperini come metodo di
pagamento
cosa dite non è moneta questa
non vi preoccupate sto bene non ha
esagerato con l'alcol prima di salire
sul palco ma la domanda che vi sto
ponendo po un temperino essere moneta
non è di per sé così strampalata e non è
di per sé è così distante dalla domanda
se il bitcoin la celeberrima moneta
virtuale possa essere considerata moneta
ora in teoria se noi qui tutti ci
mettessimo d'accordo che una certa cosa
può fungere da mezzo di scambio per
l'acquisto di beni e servizi
beh potremmo essere indotti a pensare
che abbiamo creato la nostra moneta cioè
uno strumento appunto finalizzato a
realizzare delle transazioni comprare
bottigliette d'acqua ora questa cosa ben
può essere un temperino di metallo un
pezzo di carta con dei disegnini carini
il volto di personaggi illustri
oppure se vogliamo essere un po più
tecnologici al passo con i tempi una
rappresentazione digitale di valore che
circola su un registro distribuito un
beat coni
ora l'ambizione del bitcoin è proprio
delle monete virtuali in generale è
proprio quella di soppiantare il
tradizionale metodo di emissione
circolazione della moneta in favore di
forme di pagamento alternative
concordate tra di noi
sapete qual è la cosa più affascinante
del beat coni delle monete virtuali
probabilmente alcuni di voi quelli più
familiari col the map staranno pensando
alla tecnologia sottostante loro
funzionamento e di certo è molto
affascinante lo mette in dubbio secondo
me però la cosa più affascinante del
cripto valute dell'innovazione
finanziaria degli ultimi tempi più in
generale è
la situazione di incertezza che hanno
determinato hanno provocato un vero e
proprio scossone le fondamenta della
finanza
consentitemi l'immagine ci hanno dato
uno schiaffo quella che in inglese si
direbbe una wake up call un campanello
d'allarme
ha messo in discussione cioè quello che
davamo per scontato
la moneta ma certo che sappiamo che
cos'è la moneta c'è una banca centrale
che la netta e una certa politica
monetaria
determinate regole di circolazione
insomma è la bici della finanza beh
dall'oggi al domani in giapponese dal
nome impronunciabile se ne viene fuori
che non serve avere una banca centrale
dietro basta una serie di
scritture crittografiche abbiamo il
nostro strumento di pagamento
beh
tutto questo ci ha portato a riflettere
su quella che è la qualificazione
giuridica del bitcoin la qualificazione
giuridica è il nome l'etichetta che il
diritto assegna le cose le situazioni ai
fenomeni per determinare quelle che sono
le conseguenze che ne derivano così ad
esempio se qualifichiamo un individuo un
soggetto come imprenditore questa
etichetta determina tutta una serie di
conseguenze per quello che riguarda
quello che può fare non può fare i suoi
doveri ed eventuali responsabilità
oppure
soglia eccoli in fondo che vedo le
persone particolarmente vicine se
qualifichiamo questa situazione come
assembramento ne derivano determinate
conseguenze giuridiche non
particolarmente piacevoli e che potete
immaginare allora come qualifichiamo
giuridicamente del bitcoin
possiamo qualificare il bitcoin come
moneta con tutte le conseguenze che ne
derivano
e per quel che qui ci interessa della
nostra favoletta di fedro possiamo
qualificare un temperino come moneta con
la conseguenza che posso acquistare la
tanto agognata bottiglietta d'acqua
ora vi risparmio il dibattito e cime di
inchiostro che sono stati versati per
segnare la linea di confine tra bitcoin
moneta bottigliette d'acqua e chi più ne
ha più ne metta e arrivo all'esito del
del dibattito appunto primo si è preso
coscienza di cosa è moneta secondo si è
preso coscienza di cosa non è moneta e
terzo infine si è liberato affrancato il
temperino moneta dal confronto con i
bitcoin dal confronto con la moneta e
gli essere data una sua etichetta un
nome suoi propri ma veniamo a noi
quanti qui si sentono temperino alzate
la mano
non vi preoccupate non è una cosa cosi
brutta io mi son sentito in molte
occasioni temperini allo sempre superata
bene sentirsi temperino fuor di metafora
significa trovarsi in una situazione di
incertezza di dubbio di poca chiarezza
circa il proprio destino e la propria
qualificazione il tema appunto
dell'etichetta di tutte queste varie
situazioni in cui ha avuto una sindrome
di temperini ta bene voglio raccontare
una forse la più importante di tutte per
me
macchina del tempo dieci anni indietro
siamo al termine del mio dottorato di
ricerca
quel percorso di studi che dopo la
laurea ti impegna altri tre anni con
l'ambizione alla speranza di una
carriera accademica di diventare
professore vedete io davo per scontato
che sarei entrato immediatamente
all'università dopo il mio dottorato di
ricerca
per me il momento di incertezza è stato
invece trovarmi disoccupato e con tutta
una serie di porte chiuse in faccia alla
fine del mio dottorato se non che trovo
un bel bando in una università olandese
cercano un laureato in giurisprudenza
io sono laureato in economia iniziamo
bene qualcuno che conoscesse bene il
diritto della concorrenza
io sono appassionato di diritto bancario
non sapevo sapevo poco o nulla di
diritto della concorrenza benissimo e
infine qualcuno che parlasse l'olandese
fosse disposto ad impararlo è quantomeno
avesse un livello di inglese
particolarmente elevato ora di risparmio
potete immaginare da buon italiano che
tipo di inglese potesse avere dieci anni
fa
beh su queste premesse ho presentato
domanda ha superato le prime selezioni e
sono è stato invitato alla prova orale
al colloquio ci scusi ma lei cos'è se
alle ore atene economia e si occupa di
diritto aim e uil ei muri sposi sono un
animale strano è vero non sono né
giurista né economista mi pongo nel
mezzo e sono appassionato di diritto
bancario e dei mercati finanziari e
penso che pure i vostri studenti
olandesi se ne possano appassionare
senza nulla togliere al diritto della
concorrenza per carità
vedete in quel momento forse davvero per
la prima volta ho capito che non potevo
dare per scontato quello che avrei fatto
come mestiere ne potevo dare per
scontato il come hall dove avrei svolto
quel mestiere
ho preso coscienza di me io a insegnare
in inglese in una università olandese un
corso di diritto della concorrenza
pazzia o appunto ho preso coscienza di
me della mia etichetta della mia
qualificazione come direbbero i giuristi
aim e uil animo sono un temperino e ne
vado fiero un'etichetta mia propria
diversa
vinsi quel concorso in olanda ed ottenne
oltre all'insegnamento del diritto della
concorrenza anche grazia di una cattedra
di diritto bancario
a distanza di tempo chi mi assunse mi
svelò che mi scelsero proprio perché ero
un po giurista e un po economista e
soprattutto perché ebbi il coraggio di
esibire l'interesse per il diritto
bancario ha dimostrato chi sei e non ci
avresti dovuto essere ora credo che
l'incertezza abbia tantissimi difetti ma
penso anche che abbia il pregio di
imporci a guardare le cose con sguardo
diverso a capire un po di più chi siamo
qual è la nostra qualificazione
come anticipavo fin dall'inizio
purtroppo questo mio aneddoto a cavallo
tra favola di febbre vita personale non
vi lascia con la formula magica per
l'investimento milionario i bitcoin mi
dispiace quella la tengo per me
ma spero di aver fatto qualcosa di più
utile e cioè aver insinuato il dubbio
circa la qualificazione giuridica del
bitcoin l'etichetta il suo vero nome
o forse mi sono spinto a un po che la e
vi ho contagiato con il coraggio
l'audacia ad accogliere i momenti di
incertezza della vostra vita come
occasioni per riflettere sulla vostra
etichetta e sulla vostra qualificazione
d'altro canto diciamocelo chi venderebbe
mai una bottiglietta d'acqua per un
temperino
grazie